fast forward to you
going on your tours and uh it's
33 confirmed in four months uh
what is the difference between your
first confirmed versus your 33rd come
from what was the difference between
nicholas on his first versus the 33rd
the my first one in my career ever i was
18.
i was a machine gunner with my first
ever and my first as a sniper
well i killed 33 as a sniper as a
machine gunner i legitimately have no
idea it was a few
i would maybe as much as uh a sniper
maybe a little bit less
but it was it was a bit and the first
one as a
18 year old kid i had a dream about it
for many many years and as a sniper
it was a separation i think of how close
it was
like being able to see something and the
intent behind it
was more personal so i had the sniper
kills set everything apart from any
other kill
and every sniper kill that i had was all
weird not weird
but they all felt different
yeah they all felt different i never
there was nothing that feeling that some
people say oh you get used to it i never
felt that
i never felt used to killing anything
i would have this weird set of emotions
that i would go through
and the motto for our sniper community
is uh without warning without remorse
without warning part
nine times out of ten is what happened
but the remorse part for me personally
was
every single time i felt some weird way
about it i'm not sure if it you know
derives from coming from a religious
background
and you know growing up in church and
stuff like that but
i was it was weird it was a weird
experience for me
to after the fact really weird
you're the first person that i've heard
say the disposition that you have it's
typically the other way around which is
it's part of my job it's part of my duty
and i wanted to be good you know you
know you know
it's almost like a script that you hear
but you're you're saying yeah yeah
did you when you were active did you
have contact with your parents like did
you talk your mom and dad could you come
in so when the first time it happened as
a sniper did you call your mom and dad
and try to process it with them like
here's what i'm thinking how do i handle
this
and what feedback is that i give you
my first kill ever i i remember going to
i was in iraq and i went to uh
across the street to this mwr place and
i forget what
mwr stands for um but it's the
we had like computers and stuff in there
and internet access
um we could go in there and go online
and make phone calls and i called my dad
my first kill ever no i emailed him then
called him
and he told me hey don't talk about that
stuff but i was like dad i
killed somebody and he's like hey don't
talk about that and
we never talked about it after any time
after but it was my very first kill ever
ever in combat it was like uh just eight
a little bit over 18
i was in to crit uh to crit
at that point yeah my first deployment
to iraq was to correct second one
was to mosul and the third was to
baghdad so the crit was my first kill
ever
mwr united states army families and
moral welfare
welfare and recreation programs there it
is i knew recreation was in there yep
that's what it was
yeah yeah so and so so you call your dad
and that says listen this is not
something we talked about so you're kind
of like okay
i'm gonna keep it to myself and you go
back at it and you're having 33 total
and each one of them has a different
feeling and emotion for it
are you at a point right now where you
can live your normal life and it doesn't
haunt you anymore
i am now i would say i am now um
i think that maybe over time i don't
think it'd ever go away because it
happened like
there was a point in time where i never
wanted to forget any of this stuff i
thought it was it was just stuck and
i was fine with it it was who i it made
me who i was
at that moment but then it started to
like really affect my personal life and
family life and
that guy did not intermingle with this
world you know
too well so it took some time and it
honestly legitimately was the birth of
my son
uh four years ago four years ago was the
complete 100
turn around you know from being i had to
be
it was just a weird weird thing i from
everything i've ever
ever experienced watching my son being
born in the room was
like i don't know it was out of body
experience maybe
weird i've never felt that before it was
just really really intense really weird
and
and scary yeah scary at the same time
really scared that was a different
scared though but it changed me in a
good way
i just couldn't be i don't know it was
like
i didn't matter so much anymore it
wasn't being
like me you know what i mean i didn't
have to be me
it was like i have to be cool for this
guy
are different for this guy it was just a
weird
trend it was a weird thing you know
nicholas when's your birthday what
month's your birthday
november november 28th me and my son
share the same birthday
and weird weird weird thing happened my
son was born
well he had this heart condition his uh
heart would
skip every once in a while and my sis my
wife's sister just lost her baby
12 hours 12 12 hours after uh she was
born
she had a heart condition as well so i
was you know already worried about it
and the doctors were going to you know
induce labor
the i think it was december december 8th
is when they wanted to induce it
but when i first met my wife 13 years
ago
i told her i wanted to have a child no
later than 30
and on my birthday is when my son was
born i was like
so we share the same birthday now so if
you like this sort of short clip from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye
[Music]
you